well mr. president we've already watched
you and it was really wonderful to watch
you and president Trump with some very
important and I think historic
observations today I think everybody
started the press conference with a
great deal of apprehension and I could
feel the sigh of relief in the room and
to think that we are going to be working
together again and I want to say special
thank you to you mr. president because
it showed your leadership your skill in
leading the European Commission and the
European community we're delighted to
have you here ladies and gentlemen I
will be taking too much time if we don't
let him speak because of the press
conference that went long we're not
going to be able to take questions but
he does have her prepared remarks would
you please now with your warm applause
welcome the president of the European
Commission Claude
[Applause]
chairman distinguished guests ladies and
gentlemen it is a real pleasure to be
with you tonight and it was your
pleasure to wait for me because the
President must have we need the time it
took three hours or something like like
that but we did it I'm happy to be back
in Washington a city I have only found
memories of I always remember my visit
here as a young permanent in August 1995
when I met President Clinton in the
White House at that time he had been in
office for two and a half year and as we
sat down he asked please explain you to
me I said do you have easier questions
but he insisted my experience since then
is that this is a question American
presidents always asked halfway through
their first terms but by the end of the
term and at that time in office they
tend to know you better than most
Europeans do themselves the one who
wrote that sentence didn't ask my advice
I don't believe that because Europeans
know European Union but I'm not sure
that this rule over the years I have
been lucky enough to come back many
times and work with a number of
different presidents President Clinton
President Bush President Obama and now
President Trump and I have seen over the
years our partnership evolve and grow in
many different ways but one thing has
always remained constant the
relationship between the United States
and European Union is
a unique one it is built on shared
history shared values shared interests
working together makes us both safer and
more prosperous but what makes the
transatlantic partnership so special is
that it is first and foremost a personal
affair it is part of our family stories
and part of the very fabric of our
societies many Americans of Italian
Irish polish or other European doesn't
feel a closed affinity to our continent
and authorities all around Europe these
rules are reflected in cities and towns
right across this great country and form
part of the wonderful diversity of the
United States and by the same token
Europeans have a bond with the United
States that cuts deep this is in no
small part down to crucial role played
by the United States in liberating
Europe in the first half of the 20th
century
speaking as a Luxembourg this is
something which has been with me for my
whole life not far away from where I was
born is a small town called wilts it was
the site of the Battle of the Bulge
fought in the frozen arden hills so
costly in lives and so crucial for our
freedom
Villas was hit hard during the war
mainly during the Battle of the Bulge it
was largely destroyed with families
taken from their homes and young men
forcibly conscripted to the invading
invading army just like my own father
when Reese was liberated the young
corporal from the US Army's 28th
Infantry Division called Richard Balkans
decided to bring Shearer to the children
of the town but the resting up as
sint-niklaas Santa Claus as we are
saying here
that they in December 1944 brought
smiles to the faces of children and
talked to the very souls of their
parents this simple but noble gesture
has never left the hearts of the people
of ills and has and he has become a
local legend and here mr. book is
himself who impact who fills many times
to fulfill his duty as the American
Saint Nicholas and just two years ago at
the age of 94 he was awarded the highest
military honor of Luxembourg joining the
likes of President Eisenhower Winston
Churchill and the goal for the people
that wills and the people of Europe our
friendship with the United States is
personal for them and for us all
Europeans our head history matters and I
mentioned this story for three reasons
first I want to pay tribute to mr.
Brookings and all other American
soldiers for their courage and bravery
we are forever grateful
I offered as a gift to present one a
photo of the military cemetery in
Luxembourg where General Patton is
buried this with the inscription with a
word saying dear Donald let's remember
our common history and we should do that
even in more difficult times I'm saying
this secondly because many of the
children who were there that day in
December 1944 and no longer around to
tell destroy themselves at a time when
tensions might feel straight it is more
important than ever for young people on
both sides of the Atlantic to learn
about the power of our past and about
the importance of our relationship in
upholding peace democracy and freedom
around the world the third reason is
that this story shows the unbreakable
bond that makes the transit land
partnership what it is this bond
explains a lot about how we have been
able to come so far together after World
War Two the generation of our parents
and grandparents vote never again
together they lay the foundation for our
security and prosperity through Atlantic
Cooperation the Marshall Plan helped to
rebuild our communities
NATO helped to ensure our collective
security we work together in the United
Nations and other global institutions to
ensure that the authors of the past
state in the past we stood by each other
in times of need not least when European
NATO partners joined ranks with us after
article 5 was invoked for the first and
only time in history after the 9/11
attacks for that time the United States
has always been our strongest ally and
the supporter of European integration as
far back as 1953 President Eisenhower
wrote I'm quoting the uniting of Europe
is a necessity for the peace and
prosperity of Europeans and of the world
this is our reason that today as much as
it was 65 years ago bit by bit the
United States and our partners created a
global system in which rules replaced
weapons in which disputes were settled
in courts rather than on battlefields
together we overcame an empire that
challenged our vision thanks to the us
peace was whispered restored and the
transatlantic relationship became the
anchor of global stability and
prosperity and it is indispensable today
as it was ever before our economies are
more intertwined than at any point in
history the challenges we face are
global in nature
from the pressures on climate change to
migration to peace and security across
the world now is the time for
Responsible global leadership time to
renew our partnership by falling back on
what unites us trust values shared
interests
the transatlantic partnership must
remain the anchor of global stability
and the driver of our common prosperity
and nowhere is this more important than
when it comes to trade the economic
relationship between United States and
Europe is the largest and most important
in the world with which roughly one
trillion dollars worth of goods and
services every year that is nearly a
third of global trade the trade between
us creates jobs on both sides of the
Atlantic 6.9 million of them in the
United States for ports heaven freedom
in the European Union the simple truth
is is that Europe is good for American
business US companies are more than
twice as much exporting goods to the
European Union as they do exporting to
China and more than 70% of all foreign
direct investment in the u.s. comes from
Europe we have a trading partnership
that is balanced and works on both sides
yes we export more goods to the United
States than we import but when it comes
to services the US has a trade surplus
45 billion euro a figure that is rising
by lamb percent year after year this is
not a reflection of a lack of openness
or with reciprocity in fact the opposite
is true it actually shows that the trade
between us is working because our
economies best cater to each other Smith
by Anna metric our partnership is
unrivaled and it is an example of what
can be achieved by working together and
what has made it so
successful is our common belief that
rate must be fair for all and the
win-win for all this is why together we
designed a clear set of rules that
create certainty for business and
stability for our economies at a time
when certainty and stability is a
premium in the world we must hold on
that what works this is why we were
disappointed at the US government's
decision to unilaterally impose tariffs
measures on steel and aluminium on the
basis of a national security
the idea that imports of steel or
aluminium from our shop from your
closest ally could threaten the national
security of this country and this goes
against all logic and against all
history we cannot simply accept this and
we changed it today because we agreed
with them as helped to reassess this
measure in due time the same logic
applies to the car industry and I've
said many times trait was have no
winners
they only lives gas and tariffs will not
protect national security
they will only undermine Economic
Security
allow me to give you an example if the
United States puts a twenty percent
tariff on car parts and other countries
retaliated in kind it could it would
cost the US economy fifty billion
dollars from lost GDP by 2025 but they
are - we made a deal today because we
agreed that no other terrorists would be
introduced as long as we are in
negotiations so I made this argument in
favor of the President as I did a month
ago
the g7 meeting in Canada and I'm not we
explained you all the arguments I was
submitted to the meditation of the
president because we found an agreement
and if I would read out all the
arguments I have developed it could
easily appear as if I was I had not been
in the meeting but I was there and so
everything is more or less okay I'm
happy that we reached this agreement
today as I'm happy that we were signing
a trade agreement with Canada with Japan
last Tuesday and we are negotiating with
Australia New Zealand and Mercosur in
the next coming weeks and months and as
we don't want to be naive we are trying
to safeguard the highest standards in
areas such as labor safety environmental
or consumer protection and with Japan to
give in another example we agree to
create the world largest safe flow of
data area this house s was today the
case that if there is a common will
there is always a way ladies and
gentlemen
Europe is prepared to work with all
like-minded partners to create new
opportunities and to improve the global
system itself this is why I came to
Washington today not to give unsolicited
advice but to offer increased
cooperation we will always keep dialogue
open with this administration and with
all our partners in the US and as when
we believe that instead of being
distracted by murders and
countermeasures we should focus on the
real issues in global trade of which
there are many we agree with President
Trump that away the lot that needs to
change the risks global over capacity in
the
sector that continues to harm our
workers the Chinese overcapacity in
steel is exactly double of the total
capacity of the European steel
production - still too many illegal
subsidies given by governments which are
making the playing field uneven tilted
against our companies and we also need
to crack down on the forced transfer of
technologies theft from our innovators
this is why for instance we launched the
case with the World Trade Organization
against China for its legislation on
intellectual property rights to our own
messages that I passed to the Chinese
president last week at the china-us
summit Prime Minister Abe a Japan also
agreed to work on these issues during
our meeting last week we agree that the
rules as they currently stand need to be
updated to change the challenges of our
time but the only way to address these
challenges is to rewrite the rules book
together not rip it up alone the point
is that the US and European Union must
cooperate on issues of common concern
and interest we've had the same
challenges and we share many of the same
opportunities for instance we both have
very similar attitudes when it comes to
agriculture our farming sectors are the
lifeblood of many of our communities
they secure high quality food at the
affordable prices for millions of people
and they help to make our rural
economies tick a farm in Iowa and the
farmer in Ireland may work on different
fields plots of land thousands of
kilometers away from each other but they
share the same preoccupations they want
to have the tools they need to produce
high quality food was making a fair
living for their families so it makes
sense that you and the united and the
united states
work together to preserve our local
agricultural communities and traditions
in today's global world this is why for
instance we will never allow European
farmers to fall victim to trade
negotiations or trade wars and just as
we shared the same concerns we also have
carbon opportunities that we need to
capitalize on President Trump and I
discuss many of them today take energy
in 2016 the first u.s. boat exporting
American liquefied natural gas docked in
the coast of Portugal we are ready to
invest in infrastructure and new
terminals which could welcome impulsive
LNG from the United States and elsewhere
but mainly from the United States if the
conditions were right
and prices competitive is part of our
today's agreement to increase import the
liquefied gas because already now the
European Union is importing 35% of its
gas from the US this has to be brought
to a more ambitious level all these
facts that Europe will always have its
hand outstretched to the United States
we will always look for areas where we
can work together on which will
beneficial bases but at the same time we
must take our future in our own hands
this makes this means making ourselves
more United and more responsible at home
that means defending ourselves with all
legal means when we face unfair
practices or have unfair measures aimed
at us that means making the most of
opportunities with like-minded partners
across the world just as we have done
with Japan and Canada as we are doing
with countries in Latin America
Australia resilient and as we did today
at the white house it means working to
improve and shape the global uu based
system so that it continues to live at a
peace prosperity and progress it has
done for so many decades but whatever
future lies ahead our partnership with
the United States must continue to be a
driving force for both sides and for the
world
as was reaffirmed by the US Congress
just last year on the occasion of our
60th anniversary the transatlantic
partnership is enduring
we have been through thick and thin
together through different
administration's and political cycles
our friendship runs much deeper than
that
just like the people at Will's in
Luxembourg will tell you and this today
was a good day for the transatlantic
partnership for Europe and for the
United States of America thank you for
listening
[Applause]